The orange sky at dawn.
Snow dusted peaks.
This is the kind of beauty many
of us only see on Instagram.
And this Instagrammer delivers
these views to you for a living.
She's a new kind of celebrity
and she makes money by
promoting things to her fans.
It's a lucrative world with
billions of dollars rushing in.
As technology replaces old jobs,
it's also creating new ones.
I'm Aki Ito and I'm here to
show you the jobs of the future.
My name is Meghan Young
and I'm an Influencer.
Alright, we're heading
out for our river cruise.
At first glance, Meghan's job
doesn't seem like a job at all.
Check this out, oooh!
For a living, I go on outdoor adventures,
take photos of it, and then share it
across social media
platforms when I get home.
But unlike you and me,
Meghan gets paid to share
some of these photos.
She has almost 200,000
followers on Instagram
and all kinds of companies pay her
to endorse their products on her feed.
It can be things like technical gear
from raincoats to pants to boots.
It can be different snacks that
keep me going on the trail.
And also travel
destinations, which are my,
honestly my favorite things to do
'cause it's really fun to
explore new landscapes.
Meghan's on track to earn between
$50,000 and $100,000 over the next year.
About 10% of her feed is sponsored.
For a story post on Instagram,
that usually starts around $200 per day.
And then for posts to
the social feed channel,
about $1,500 or more for one post.
Right now, much of that
income is helping pay for this home.
Hey!
Nice to meet you.
Meghan moved in last month
with her partner, Matt.
He's a biologist and a
regular fixture on her feed.
What's it like to have a mini
celebrity as a girlfriend?
The fame, I really don't
think about it that much.
Except for when you get mad
at me for using my phone.
She uses her phone a lot, yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Replying to her followers -
Figuring out -
Yeah.
Boundaries of like,
oh, this is work time and this isn't
work time, it's definitely important.
It's a conversation we have all the time.
What's your favorite part of her job?
Probably it's when I get
to go on her adventures.
Yeah.
Is there stuff in the outdoors
that you've learned from her?
I have never been a
person to lay out my gear,
to make sure I have
everything appropriately
for each trip, I tend to wing it.
But yeah, preparedness is definitely
rubbing off a little
bit on me, which is nice
because you do have to really make sure
that you bring everything that you need.
This guy's gonna come out
and then this tent and then the boots.
Tomorrow, Meghan's taking me
on one of her signature
mountaineering adventures.
I have to make sure that
all the gear is clean,
it's repaired, that we're safe,
everything is ready to go.
She's also packing
products from two companies
she's hoping to promote on the trip:
a beer company that's an existing client
and an energy bar maker she's pitching
for a future sponsorship deal.
We're planning a four and a half mile hike
up the Cascade Mountains,
climbing around 2,500 feet.
We'll be camping overnight
and then hiking down.
The next day, we get an early start.
Good morning, it's 5:06.
Cloudy start to the day, rain
and breezy conditions expected
for Western Washington
with highs in the low 50s.
And expect showers this evening
and likely for tomorrow.
A few years ago, Meghan was in law school,
studying to become an
attorney, and it was there
that mountaineering came
in surprisingly handy.
In order to get through
the stresses of law school,
I started going back
outside with a vengeance.
I would post photos on Instagram about
the trips we'd been on
and places we had been
and eventually brands began
to take notice of that
and reach out to ask if I wanted to
collaborate in different ways.
She ended up deciding
against a career in law
and after holding an
office job for two years,
she quit in March to focus on
being an Influencer full time.
There've been tough moments along the way.
Sometimes I get pretty nasty
messages or hateful comments,
telling me how I am
allowed to use my voice
and how I'm allowed to use my platform.
I block them and I don't
have any qualms about that.
I think that doing this
job, people can think of you
as less of a real person
but I'm a very real person
with very real feelings and fears,
so it can be a little weird sometimes.
And then there's the constant
pressure to make sure people are liking,
commenting, and following her feed.
Metrics are incredibly important
in the world of social media influencing.
And early on, I became really
obsessive with checking them.
And honestly, it got the
point of being exhausting.
These days, I try not to focus on it
because it will drive you insane.
And for me to live a healthy,
balanced life, I can't do that.
But we've left all that behind in Seattle.
Oh, it's cold.
It's not warm.
The blue sky's really nice.
Hopefully it moves this way.
Yeah, that's the hardest part about
this time of year in
the Pacific Northwest,
when the weather won't cooperate.
What'd you get me into?
It's gonna be great, let's go.
Let's do it.
This was supposed to be a mild hike
and it's a total breeze for Meghan
but not so much for me.
This is not easy.
I always wanna make sure
we're as safe as possible but there are
always these moments where we're
on something exposed or
we're climbing something,
I'm thinking about, what if there's
a rock fall and we plummet to our death?
Those fears are very real.
So warm outside, you guys, ahh it's crazy.
Finally, four hours behind schedule,
we arrive at the campsite.
Are we here?
Yeah, this looks like.
Yeah, woo, we did it!
This is like a really fresh
layer of snow, which is nice.
With the weather worsening,
we start boiling snow to
make water for dinner.
And remember that beer Meghan
was planning to promote?
It's way too cold for that
and she scraps her plans
for an evening photo shoot altogether.
A little past 7 pm, we
retreat into our tents,
shivering in our sleeping bags.
But after the coldest night of
my life, we wake up to this.
It's the window of good
weather Meghan was hoping for
and she uses it to stage a sponsored photo
for the energy bars she brought along.
I'm always trying to think about,
how do I take something
and make it look at home
or natural or normal in
these wild landscapes?
I think a lot of people
will be watching this
and think that this looks miserable,
why did you do this?
So why do you do it?
I am so happy out here,
it's a little ridiculous.
You wake up with mornings like this
and you sort of forget the
sweating and the heavy bags
and sort of live in that moment.
And these places, they may
not last, like global warming,
so I feel this sense of wanting
to see things while I can.
For now you get this.
Yeah, not so bad.
It's a pretty good office, I'll take it.
Meghan's post of the energy bar
has now been seen by 16,000 people
and since our trip, she's
signed sponsorship deals
with three new clients,
making the $1.6 billion market
for Instagram Influencers
just a little bigger.
But the world of social media changes fast
and Meghan knows there
are plenty of things
that could derail her newfound career.
What if Instagram goes away?
At the end of the day, I have bills to pay
and sometimes you're looking
at your calendar going,
"Do I have any projects coming up?"
and those moments are really scary.
But for now, she can't imagine
living her life any other way.
Sun came out, so beautiful.
I've had young women reach out to me
and say that they've found inspiration
or they've gone on a
hike or climbed a peak.
That's the upside to social media,
you have this ability to inspire people
and to actually touch
their lives, offline.
And that's pretty cool.